- I'm just so used to being
attacked for everything I say,
it's like at this
point I'm like,
all right, you know,
what are you gonna do?
Are you gonna call
me a mean name?
What would that feel like?
What would it feel
like to see myself
called something horrible on
every newspaper in the country?
Oh, wait, I've done that.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
this is the Rubin Report.
As always guys make sure you're
subscribed to our channel
and resubscribe when
YouTube unsubscribes you.
And joining me today is
a bestselling author,
a TV host, a journalist,
a mother, a dog lover, and
a newly minted podcaster.
Megan Kelly, welcome
to the Rubin Report.
- Hey, so good to be with you.
- A newly minted
podcaster Megan,
you're dipping your
toes in some new waters.
We're gonna talk
about everything, but
let's start there.
You're getting
back in the fight.
What are you, nuts?
- You know, I'm excited.
Like I thought when I left
NBC that I would just sort of,
maybe this could be my new life.
I would just take it easy and
I would take care of my kids,
which was very
enjoyable and remain so,
'cause they're good
ages right now.
And you know, maybe I'd
be like a lady of leisure,
see how that went.
And then I tuned
out from the news,
which was helpful.
And then, you know, bit by bit,
I started to pull me back in
and I started to read
more and more and more
and then all hell broke
loose in our country.
And like the culture wars
really just make my head spin.
And the one thing
that really made me
wanna get off the couch over
the time that I had off,
was the movie, "No Safe Spaces.
And I, I was glued to my
chair watching it and I cried.
It was, and I thought, this is,
I have to get back out there.
They're just, there
aren't enough people
who are saying the things
that need to be said.
There's too many people
who are being silenced
just for having a
dissenting voice,
a reasonable but
dissenting voice.
And if you have the opportunity
to get to a microphone
and have those discussions,
you better do it.
So here I am.
- So since I was in
"No Safe Spaces",
can I fully credit myself
for bringing Megan Kelly
back into the fight?
Is that, is that fair?
- You and Adam and Dennis
and Ben and Mark Joseph,
the producer, who I came
to know over the years.
And he's just,
he's so unsung as an
amazing filmmaker, you know,
he's doing in Hollywood,
what nobody else is doing,
which is trying to shed a light
on some conservative causes
some this even center
or center right issues.
And I'll just give you
one quick example, Dave,
when I had my show on NBC,
he called me up and he said,
I have Susette Kelo from
Kelo versus Connecticut.
You know, the case that
went all the way up
to the Supreme court.
And it was an
eminent domain case.
Does the state have the ability
to grab her little pink house,
even though she doesn't
want them to have it
under eminent domain,
like they need it.
And she, she, everybody
on my team was like,
Oh, huh, huh, right?
They weren't into it and
I was like, I want her.
So we put her on, and
Mark was the connection.
It was the highest rated
segment we had the entire time
on NBC, by far.
It was like that guy is
tapping into something.
You know, Americans want more
stories about the little guy.
They don't, they
don't live and breathe
Hollywood celebrities.
And anyway, I love Mark
Joseph and I love that movie.
And if your audience
has not seen it,
it's available now online and
it is so worth your two hours.
- Yeah, well,
you've also been
through your own version
of what we were talking
about in the movie,
which is the cancel thing and
the mob and all that stuff.
But you know, we've gotten to
know each other a little bit
in the last year,
so I didn't have to
do major research
to talk to you right now,
but I did scribble down
a couple things here.
And one of them
that I wrote down
was that how you're
getting back into the fight
and it's sorta like the
mafia pulling you back in.
And you just said you were
sort of reeled back in
by this thing.
And is that sort of how
you feel about the news,
like that you love it,
but then also you
kind of need to escape
and then it just sucks
you back in either way?
- Yes, because the
thing for me is,
I have never been
a political person.
And so I was never jazzed
up just by politics.
You know what I mean?
Like I used to look
at Charles Krauthammer
and the way he was
just, he loved politics
and he wrote about it,
the way, like it was the
most important thing ever.
And as somebody who
was raised, sort of,
non-ideological not even
watching the evening news,
we watched the Jeffersons.
I was like, you
know, I don't know.
I like covering the news,
And I like talking
about politics to
the extent it's news,
but not just beating
up politicians
and battering around issues
just to make an hour on TV.
And what happened to me was,
I started watching more
and more of the news,
and of course we had political
fights going left and right.
But I was not so
interested in getting back
to cover the latest fight
between George Conway
and president Trump at all.
But the culture wars, what's
happening in our society,
what's happening legally,
I mean, right now it's like,
this is right in my wheelhouse.
Everything is happening
with the Supreme Court.
And just more and more like
the erosion of our freedoms,
which is, you know, I
practiced law for 10 years.
It's, it's a noble
cause for which to fight
and you'll get called names
and you'll get beaten up
and it'll be very brutal,
but there are so many
people who are on your side
and I'm not saying you're
against all the things
that you're talking about,
but you're talking about
them, talking about them.
I feel like that,
that's what inspired me
to get back out here.
- Let's talk about
the Jeffersons.
- Yeah.
- George-
- Louise.
- George would probably,
George would probably
be a Republican, right?
Like he was a successful-
- Probably.
- Business owner, you know,
moved on up to the East side.
He'd probably be a Republican.
- You're probably right,
he did build that.
Although I don't know,
Marla Gibbs, the maid.
I don't, she was my favorite.
I'm not sure, she'd probably
give him a hard time for it.
- Oh, she would.
That was Florence,
she would definitely-
- Florence.
- Give him a hard time.
Speaking of, speaking
of New York city,
you are actually in New
York city right now.
What the hell is going on
in New York city right now?
- Oh my God, it's like,
you know, to me, it's sad
because I've lived here,
I mean, off and on, I've
lived here for 15, 17 years
and we moved to
the Upper West side
because it had become
a neighborhood.
It had become a safe place
where you could raise your kids
and you could stroll
down the sidewalks
and with good
schools and you know,
cute little bodegas
where you could just go
and get a bagel, whatever.
And, and in like a year,
our mayor ruined it.
He, I mean, you really
have to tip your hat to him
because it's not easy
to wreck New York,
but he did it.
And I mean, we're
gonna come back,
I don't believe for one second,
that New Yorkers are gonna
lie down and stay lying down.
But boy, this mayor's
given us quite a,
quite a fight 'cause the
city is totally different
than it was just before
I left for quarantine.
I mean, it's depressing.
It looks like 1970s New York,
where I came all the time
'cause my nana lived here.
It's like, it's not even just,
there is obviously a
massive homeless problem on,
on the Upper West side in
particular where I live,
because he moved, he
built three hotels up here
with homeless people,
without any plan.
1/3 of them were
convicted pedophiles.
And it's like, well, you know,
maybe we could use
a heads up on that,
a plan on how to deal with it.
No, he didn't.
It's like walking
down the street
and just hearing
so much profanity,
which I like a good swear
just as much as anybody else,
but I try not to drop
them in front of my kids,
in front of my seven year old,
but the vulgarity too Dave,
it's just like, I'm gonna
take the F and this,
and I'm gonna do this
to you, you know,
somebody in the cell
phone talking, like,
I'm so sad about
it, I feel loss.
- Yeah, you know, I used
to live on the Upper West
and when I've gone back over
the last couple of years,
every time I go back,
I'm like, hi, it's a little
worse than last time.
A little worse than last time.
And now I haven't been
back since lockdown,
but I told you my sister
and her husband and kids,
they got out of there.
And it's like, what
kind of future does the,
does the city have?
Do you think people
make the connection
between what's happening,
like on the ground there
and the fact that
de Blasio's policies
are actually what cause it?
- Oh, yes.
- Yeah, you think they do?
- Hundred percent.
He has such a low approval
rate here in Manhattan.
It's under 25%, I think,
according to the
latest poll I saw.
The Democrats have
turned on him,
the Republicans have
never been a fan.
I remember having
him on my show on Fox
when he was running, and he
was like last in the poll.
This is back when Anthony Wiener
was supposed to win that mayoral
race, don't get me started.
And, and I remember
saying city advocate,
what the hell is that?
Nobody ever heard of
you, you have no chance.
And he was like, 'Oh, I got
a chance, I could do it."
Like, what do you do
with city advocate,
I still don't understand.
But I do know now,
he and his wife
are talking about, you know,
layoffs and furloughs.
And yet his wife still
has her $140,000 a year
speech writer.
She's got her videographer
following her around,
while the trash
bins are overflowing
on the streets of New York.
The restaurant
owners are suffering.
These mom pop shops, which were
already suffering under him
have now gone out of business
with no hope of coming back.
So, you know, I hope she
gives a really good speech,
because we're all paying for it.
- Yeah, exactly.
So you mentioned
that the culture war
is partly what's, what's
bringing you back.
And I remember watching you on,
on Fox, you know, years ago.
And what I liked
about you was that,
well, you're just, first off,
some people just know how
to talk to the camera.
Like you just know how
to do it first off.
Was that just always
very natural to you
that you could just be
yourself just like that?
- No, no, I would not say that.
I mean, if you go back and look
at some of my earliest hits
on Fox and I was on ABC
local, in DC prior to that,
they're very stilted, they're,
they're pretty stilted.
I, you know, very, right?
And I always say about
television, it's like typing.
The more you do, the better
you get, the smoother you get.
But you know, you cannot
get the 70 words a minute
without doing 20, 30, 40.
So I always tell
the young people
who are coming up behind me,
like who wanna be good on TV,
Just practice.
Just say yes to every hit.
There's nothing
that's below you,
do it and do it often,
do it even when you
don't wanna do it.
And then one day you wake
up and it's not hard.
- Yeah, it's weird, I
look back and I'm like,
man, 20 years ago, when I
was like a struggling comic,
I was doing, you know, 4:00 AM
radio hits, and it was like,
I was like willing to
absolutely do anything.
And I look back and I'm
like, why was I doing that?
But I, I guess maybe it
worked at some level, right?
- Yeah, it ships in the bank.
And honestly, even
just the exercise
of getting on your
feet, you know,
like comics have that
experience, which is so helpful.
And I, as a lawyer had that
as well, which was helpful.
But like, you gotta
keep doing it.
That's a muscle
that needs exercise.
Like getting up there,
making your point.
I used to practice
on a little phone,
like I'm looking into right now.
And I would pretend to do
a television hit, you know,
like there was a fire
down on 54th today,
which is made up
news, fake news.
And my, my rule for myself was,
I couldn't stop,
so no matter what,
if I stumble, I have to do
60 seconds on the fake fire.
And it was very helpful because
usually you can stop
and you can have a redo.
And as you know,
in live television,
you cannot.
- All right, let's see how
seasoned you are right now.
Give me 60 seconds
on that fake fire.
I think it's on
62nd on West End.
- "On 62nd on West End,
oh, it came to a halt today
as firetruck came to the
scene within two minutes
of the first 911 call.
The blaze turned into
a four alarm fire,
putting lives at risk, yet the
FDNY did what it always does,
saved lives and
protected the community.
More as we get it, back to you."
- Oh my God, a
true professional.
You haven't lost it,
you haven't lost it.
- Thank you.
- So anyway,
so I remember truly, I
remember watching you on Fox
and it was like, you had
that thing with the camera,
but also I think what
you said before is right.
Like you didn't
strike me as someone
that was consumed by
the political thing.
And yet now it
seems like everyone,
not just people in the
world that we're in,
everyone, everywhere,
sports world,
fashion world, doesn't
matter what world.
You could be a shoe shiner,
you could be a, you know,
selling, you can be
working at Petco.
It doesn't matter what it is.
Everything is freaking
political right now.
I know you kind of see
that as much of a danger
as I do, right?
That sort of-
- Yeah,
it's my worst nightmare.
It's my worst nightmare
because what I love
and one of the reasons
I love practicing law,
was debating issues.
I like to be persuaded.
I'd love to be told
that I'm wrong,
and then be brought
over to the other side.
I know you do too,
because I'm open
minded to being wrong.
You know, I always say,
I'm a learn it all,
not a know it all.
And now it's just, I listened
to some hard partisans,
you know, I listen to
certain podcasts and so on.
And it's interesting and
it's sort of like a tickler,
like this is what it's
like on this side,
but I'm, I always
end up thinking,
I just don't wanna
be that person.
I'm just not at heart
this hard partisan person.
I'm not, I wouldn't describe
myself as a moderate though,
because I have strong
points of view.
You know, what I
believe, I really believe
and I feel strongly about,
but so I'm not kind
of wishy washy,
but I also feel no
loyalty either side.
I'm not, I'm certainly
not a loyal Democrat.
I've been a
registered Republican,
but I'm a registered
Independent now.
I've been a registered
Democrat too, by the way.
And I just, I look at
these parties and I'm like,
yeah, you don't represent me,
but you know, I'll take what
I believe in from both sides.
- Yeah, and yet
everyone seems to have
to make a political statement
about everything constantly.
So if you were had to,
if you had to describe your
political beliefs right now,
like what is that?
What are they?
- I mean, I would
say I'm center-right
on a lot of issues.
I'm center-left on
some other issues.
I took a test online that
says like, what are you?
You know, and when I, when I,
yeah, and it said I was a
conservative Republican,
and I was like, ah, and then I
had Doug, my husband take it,
and it said, he's a
conservative Republican.
And we're both Independents
who have voted for
Democrats and Republicans,
you know, like all
throughout our lives.
So I just think like the
country's moving so far left
to some extent, like the,
the things that used to be
center-left or even center
are now right,
established right.
So I don't know
when that happened,
but I would still
vote for a Democrat
if I saw the right
one, you know?
And I don't know,
I'm certainly not hard down
the party line Republican.
There are a lot of
them who I don't like,
and I voted against.
- Yeah, so what was
it like for you,
to sort of be someone that
was supposed to be talking
about the news, but also for
a lot of the time you were,
you were kind of making news.
I mean, everyone knows the,
what happened with
Trump and the debates,
but that you sort of got
sucked into news too.
And in the movie, there's
a line where Nicole Kidman
as you basically
says that you know-
- No, no, Charlize Theron
- Oh, sorry Charlize
Theron where she says,
you know, that she, you,
basically saying, you know,
you didn't wanna
be making the news.
I assume that's pretty
much how you feel.
- Yeah, I said,
I'm not gonna be the story,
I don't wanna be the story.
And, and I was the
story after that debate
and I hated it.
And I have hated being the
story every time it's happened.
You know, I see the
journalists as, as you know,
on the sidelines, not
as players on the field
and you know, Trump, to
some extent grabbed me
and put me on the field and
the Roger Ailes thing did too.
And then just, I don't know,
once you get well
known, you know,
the sleazy media takes
a big interest in you
and starts following you around.
And they're not all
bad, some guys are good.
There's actually a sweet
guy, right after I left NBC,
all these paparazzi were
outside of my apartment.
And you know, couldn't
like leave without getting
(imitates cameras clicking)
And this one guy who was from
The Post, he got his shot.
He's like, and then he goes,
this is such bullshit Megan,
you can't say anything anymore.
Like, there are real people
out there they're not all bad,
but I don't like being
the topic of the news.
I have asked myself many times
why that keeps happening.
You know, I think,
I think people aren't used
to seeing like somebody
they can't figure out,
somebody who's sort of
unapologetically strong,
especially, especially a
woman, we're out there,
but like, it's not that common.
And a woman who
doesn't mind fighting.
Right, like it's like,
what, what, what you doing?
But you know that I'm
feudalistic by nature.
And I think it, it
may be exciting.
It may be upsetting, you
know, maybe alienating,
but for whatever reason,
it's attractive news.
- Yeah, it's funny to me
because as you're getting back
into the fray, like,
it's so obvious,
there's gonna be a moment
like within a couple of months
where something's gonna happen,
like you're gonna say
something or one of your guests
is gonna say, sorry, psych.
And you're gonna be like,
"Ugh, why did I get back in?"
But then, but then an
hour later you'll be like,
this is exactly
why I got back in.
Like, that's just a negotiation.
- I don't think that's
going to happen to me.
I mean, I do think they're
gonna come after me,
you know, knives out,
but I'm just so used to being
attacked for everything I say,
it's like, at this
point, I'm like,
"All right, you
know, what do you,
what are you gonna do, are you
gonna call me a mean name?"
What would that feel like?
What would it feel like to
see myself called something
horrible in every
newspaper in the country?
Oh, wait, I've done that.
In a way it's sort of
empowering 'cause it's like,
they, they took their best shot.
I'm here, I'm well, I'm happy.
I'm about to launch something
that I'm really into.
And for once Dave, like,
they can't get rid of me.
They can't get rid
of me, you know?
Like even if every sponsor
I have is like, "We're out!"
Then I'll do
subscription, you know,
the relationship will be
between me and my audience
and they can't stop it,
whether they want to or not,
they can't stop it.
I will have my say,
I will have these discussions
with interesting provocative
people, people who
go against the grain.
And if the audience is there,
I will remain on the air.
- You're speaking
my language, sister.
I may be able to retire
- I know.
- I may be able to retire early
now that you're getting back in.
- What do you mean?
We're gonna go off to
the sunset together,
the digital sunset.
- Ah, the digital,
There you go.
All right, so let's
talk a little bit
about just like generally
what's going on in the world
right now.
You know, the racism stuff,
the, the riots, the protests,
we'll get to COVID in a sec.
What do you make about
what is happening here?
It seems to me that we're
just sort of watching
the entire fabric that we've
had here for 200, you know,
almost 50 years
basically unravel,
that just sort of this
idea that this whole thing
was founded on racism and
that's the driving force
behind everything.
It strikes me as so dangerous.
And yet it's so
sort of accepted,
which is kind of what
you were saying before
about that, that the
left seems to have taken
so much control of this stuff.
What do you make of what's
happening right now with race
and the conversation?
- Well, I think it's very
frustrating for people like me,
like you, who would like to
be allies to people of color,
to black people, anybody
who feels ostracized
and suffers from racism.
And yet there's no way in,
without somehow
completely embracing
the insane messaging from a
group like "Black Lives Matter".
I think most normal people
believe there is racism
in the country, but that
we are not a racist country
and that they don't believe
we were founded on racism.
And even, even the New York
times with this 1619 project
is slowly withdrawing all
those names from its piece
without highlighting
the withdrawal.
They're just like,
"Oh, that stuff was said
about being founded on racism
and the whole point about like,
you know, keeping slavery,
nevermind erase it,
which is so dishonest.
- It's literally, that's
what literally happened.
- For a news organization
not to call attention
to the deletion, that's
a massive deletion
and it caused a
lot of controversy
and they're just slowly
taking it down, it's not true.
The country wasn't founded
to hold on to slavery
and it isn't a racist country.
It did used to be,
you know what I mean?
Back in slavery, Jim Crow,
we had massive problems.
But the thing that
bothers me about
what's happened over
the past few months,
is it's based on a lie.
It is based on a lie.
Not the George Floyd
case that was disturbing.
And that case will play out
appropriately in the court.
But the lie that
police are systemically
and as a group, hunting
black people, it isn't true.
And even, you know, I
think that was the term
LeBron James used, you know,
something about how a
black person or black man
can't even go outside where
they're getting hunted,
wrong and the data are there
and the people who cite the
data get just so maligned.
But if you look like here
in New York, in the 1970s,
the murders per year,
the shootings per year
were in the 400, 400 plus.
Couple of years ago, they
were down to like 36, right?
So it's like, stop the behavior,
is going in the right direction,
there are some bad apples.
We all know that in any
profession, there are, right?
Certainly in our profession.
But if you look
at the actual data
of the number of
black unarmed men,
'cause it's always men
who get killed by police
compared to their number of
interactions with police,
their crime rate, it's not
disproportionate, right?
Because the studies will show
and Jason Riley of the Wall
Street Journal, who is black,
has been doing a great
job covering this,
that over 50% of
the violent crimes
are committed by black men.
And that is why they have
a higher interaction rate
with police in part.
And therefore the
stakes go up, right?
The stakes go up for this
given the history between them.
It's, it's brought for
a negative encounter.
And then for potentially
something deadly to happen.
I'm not saying it's good.
I'm just saying you can't
attribute it to racism
without factoring
in crime rates.
- Yeah, so do you think
that the Democrats
have sort of gone too deep
on this kind of stuff?
This is where, you know,
for someone like me, that
used to be a left, you know,
I was a lefty, I was a
Democrat, the whole thing
where it's like every
message that now
pretty much comes
out of the left is,
this is a racist nation, this
is racism, racism, racism.
And then the average person,
if you cite any
of those studies,
or if you read any
book by Thomas Sowell
or listen to any
talk by Larry Elder,
they'll somehow tell
you that, you know,
well, they'll actually
call those guys sell outs
or uncle Toms or something else.
But then even the fact
that you've cited them,
they'll use as
proof of your racism
because you found a black
person that agrees with you.
And it's almost like
there's just nothing left
to talk about, it's very
depressing actually.
- I mean, I think for, you know,
me and you, like, I
don't really care.
Like, it's fine.
You can call me whatever
you wanna call me.
I'm gonna say, what's true.
I am going to say the facts and
if you don't like the facts,
you don't have to
listen to me, great.
You can go, you wanna
write, write up what I said,
good, bad, or ugly go for it.
That's just more
exposure of my worldview,
but you don't have to listen.
I think it's more
problematic for, you know,
the civilians, if
you will, right?
People who don't engage
in punditry for a living
because they're scared,
they've genuine.
I would say like the
most disturbing part
about the end of my time at
NBC was the message it sent
to the folks on the
street, which is you say
one "wrong thing" you're
dead, you know, you're dead.
And that is just not the country
most of us wanna live in.
You know, it really upsets me
when I see what's
happening with teenagers.
You know, like these teenagers
who are getting
their lives ruined
because they say
and do stupid stuff,
just like we all said
and did stupid stuff.
And now no more, in this
day and age, you're done.
- Yeah, so I don't
wanna rehash all the,
all the past stuff
in NBC and all that.
But I did see recently when,
when Kim Klacik was running
for a representative,
I think it's district
7 in Baltimore,
she was on The View, she
got into it with the ladies
and a little bit of
a cat fight started.
And she basically
said, well, Joy,
talking to Joy Behar, you
know, you've been in blackface
and you had a
pretty clever tweet
about the sort of double
standard on this stuff,
that sort of, if
you're a lefty liberal,
you can kind of get away with
not only being in blackface,
but also pretending that
the whole black community,
as Joy said, sort
of supports her,
where it was a little
different for you.
- Well, well, I think
what Joy was arguing
was that she was
never in blackface
because she intended her
blackface Halloween costume
to be an homage-
- Homage.
- To black women,
that's what she said.
It was a homage.
And you know, it's funny
because I remember people
saying very clearly
when I tried to
discuss this issue
about whether there
could ever be an instance
where you were trying
to honor someone
where it might be acceptable
and all hell broke loose.
And so I was waiting,
I was waiting to see,
and she works for ABC, I
was waiting to see a report
on world news tonight, right?
Like, like they
did with me on GMA,
like they did with me on NBC.
NBC was totally
interested in my comments,
but I didn't see Lester Holt,
hover, Joy Behar's comments.
And yet the whole world
gave a very strong message
that you may never,
you, homage, no,
intent is not
relevant, it's not.
And even just last week,
Chris Rock was saying
intent is relevant in
talking about why he forgave
Jimmy Kimmel or Jimmy Fallon
for playing him
with blackface on.
So anyway, I, of course
there's a double standard,
you know, it's like,
you gotta live with it,
you can't just like boo hoo,
but it's kinda fun to
call attention to it
because they just
can't get out of it.
You know what I mean?
The left is, like the
media, is so dishonest
and I really make no
distinction between the left
and the media.
Other than Fox and sort of
declared conservative media,
there are no conservative
outlets or even center
or independent outlets,
they're all left.
- So that's actually kind of
where I wanted to go next.
So what do you make of just
generally like the state
of journalists and
well, first off,
do you consider cable
pundits and all of the faces
and even, you know what I do,
and the other people that
are doing this on YouTube
and everywhere else,
like, do you consider
all of us journalists?
Like, I don't consider
myself a journalist.
I'm telling people what I
think, I'm interviewing people,
but I'm not out in
the field, you know,
collecting information
and reporting on it.
I can, I can read a story
and process it and tell
people what I think.
But, but I think a lot of
people think that Don Lemon
is a journalist, like
I don't consider him
or Chris Cuomo, a
journalist or even Tucker,
I don't consider a journalist.
What, do you think
that even matters,
like what we're calling them?
- I think it matters.
I think there's still a
distinction between journalists
and pundits and you know,
opinion journalists,
that's another sort of category.
I think the problem with
somebody like Lemon or Cuomo
is they don't, they're
not honest about it.
They actually think they're
straight news journalists.
So I'm told is Rachel Maddow.
She thinks she's a
straight news journalist
and I've got no beef with
Rachel Maddow, it's fine.
She can say what she
wants every night,
but let's not pretend it's fact,
that it's journalisticly
sound, it's not.
And you need look no
further than her coverage
of Russia Gate
for proof of that.
- Yeah.
- I think it's amazing
that they'll put those guys
on CNN out there at presidential
debate as moderators,
trying to pawn them
off to the audience
as straight news guys,
you know that they are,
they are not straight news
journalists, they're not.
And even like Fox
would never use Tucker
for a presidential debate,
but Tucker is a journalist.
He's got a background
in journalism,
but he's morphed over
to the opinion side,
but his, his background
is in journalism,
but I think he's morphed
over to the opinion side
and he doesn't
make any, you know,
secret of that.
Fox news would never
have Sean Hannity
sitting there anchoring
a presidential debate,
or at least they wouldn't
have when I was there.
'Cause they understood, you
got the journalist, you know,
like Harris Faulkner and
Brett Baer who do journalism,
journalism, inc.
And then you've got the
independent, journalism inc,
and then you got
the opinion folks
who are great at what they do.
- Yeah, do you think
journalism can come back?
I mean, you probably see me
do it on Twitter all the time,
but every time I have to
write the word journalist
or journalism, I have to
put air quotes around it
because it seems just
so absolutely far gone.
- I don't have a
lot of hopes for it.
I gotta be honest, I
don't know that it can.
I think, you know,
more and more we're
moving into this land
where there's no demilitarized.
Let me try to say that again,
there's no demilitarized zone,
you know, it's like people are,
they're forcing
you to pick a side
and I don't think that
I'm not sure people really
even want, you know,
crazy sort of uncle
Walter, he wasn't crazy,
but you know what I mean?
Like the sort of, let me
tell you the news anymore.
I think they kind of want spin.
They want a little bit of
their worldview reflected.
And I actually
think that that's,
that's why some of the Fox
news journalists do so well.
Like if you watch
Brett Bear's program,
he understands who
his audience is.
It is not a newscast
that reflects
what you read in the
New York times, right?
This is what I used to
do on the Kelly file.
So you understand who you're
programming to, right?
But then you discuss the news
in a way that's truly fair
and balanced.
So it's not diminishing or
dismissive of either side.
The way it always is if
you see anything discussed,
especially cultural issues
on these other channels,
like when was the last
time you heard MSNBC
discuss homeschooling
in any way,
other than with disgust
or the second amendment
or religion in the
public square, you know,
they they're disgusted by people
who believe in those things
and it shows.
So anyway, I don't
have high hopes for it.
I see us getting more
and more partisan
and retreating to those corners.
- Yeah, look at you
on the Upper West,
the liberal haven of the world,
and you're willing to talk
about those things, gutsy.
- You know, I've been,
I've here for a long time.
I used to, when we first
got to the Upper West side,
I said to my husband,
Doug, you know,
'Do you think it's really
as liberal as they say?"
And at that moment, this
is back in 2006 I think,
or whatever, around there,
at that moment, there's a woman
walking by with a tee shirt
that reads "Kill Cheney first".
I think I have my answer.
It's like, are you, it really
is like a comedy routine.
You walk down the block
here and it's like,
would you support Greenpeace?
Do you support
planned parenthood?
Do you sign this
thing against Trump?
Registered to vote?
You know, fascists, whatever,
it's like, take care.
Thank you, bye now.
- It's so funny, I
remember living up there
and I would go to Zabar's on
Sundays to grab a bagel and lox
and outside, you know, they'd
have those book guys outside
just with the old books.
And basically every book,
it was when George W.
Bush was president.
Every book was like, he's the
devil, he's evil, he's evil.
And I remember even
thinking back then,
even though I was really more
in that line of thinking,
I remember thinking something's
not quite right up here.
- Oh my God, you go into
our local bookstore.
Like, it's actually our
it's a children's store,
but it's got a lot of books.
And the whole wall
of books is like,
even before Ruth Bader
Ginsburg died, it was like RBG,
the notorious, and you know,
all Michelle Obama
and Hillary Clinton
and then Chelsea Clinton.
And it was like, you
know, strong women.
And like, I never saw
Condi Rice, you know?
Like they just, it's, look,
this is their politics
and that's fine.
They can have their politics,
so far we've all gotten
along respectfully.
There's a turn, there's,
there's been a turn
where it's like, suddenly,
you know how it is,
if you, if you're not
like a left wing Democrat,
he's leftist.
I don't think normal
liberals are like this,
but these leftists are, they
think you're, you're racist,
you're a bigot,
you're a xenophobe,
you're a sexist and
that's just that.
- Yeah, and then they start
showing up to, you know,
people sitting,
having dinner outside,
and next thing you know, we
got even bigger problems.
But speaking of
Ruth Bader Ginsburg,
so I know we are holding
this for a couple of days,
so I don't wanna get into the-
- Hold on, while you say that
I'm just gonna grab
a glass of water.
- Oh, I thought you had,
I thought you maybe
had like a little doll
of Ruth Bader Ginsburg
or something with you.
I don't know where you
were going with that.
- I do have a fun song about
her though if you google it,
there's one on the,
on YouTube that goes,
♪ Will you marry me ♪
♪ Ruth Bader Ginsburg ♪
♪ You're my favorite justice
on the Supreme court. ♪
My son found it when doing
some homework project.
- There you go.
We've really turned politics
into something strange.
- You're gonna cut this
part out, aren't you?
- No, we are not,
we do not edit.
And I hope that the Megan Kelly
Show also will not edit for,
are you gonna edit the content?
We don't, we don't
edit the content.
- Why didn't you tell me that?
I wouldn't said half the shit.
I don't know if I, if
I say something stupid,
I hope we take it out.
Actually, I don't even know
the answer to that, Dave.
I haven't made a philosophical
commitment not to edit,
so we'll see.
- We'll see, the
only time actually
that we edited for, you
know, we've edited out
if someone like had a coughing
fit or something like that,
only one time did
we edit for content.
And I don't wanna say
who the guest was,
but let's just say,
well, I will say it was a she
and she was extremely
high and extremely drunk.
And I probably saved her
career by editing out
about 45 minutes
of the interview.
And if someone was to
really think about it,
that is watched all
the Rubin Reports,
they could probably
figure it out.
And I, and I'll tell you after.
- Oh good, I was
just going to say,
I'm gonna go back and
search all of the old ones
just to find out.
- Yeah, but, but speaking of,
of Ruth Bader Ginsburg and
everything that's going on
with the Supreme
Court right now,
you tweeted out something
that I thought was just like,
so you framed it so correctly,
which is that's
you basically said,
and you can clean it up for me.
But in essence you
were saying like,
look, everybody's sort
of a hypocrite here
and you can sort of catch
everybody saying the rivers
when they're not in power.
But this is just
how politics works.
It just sort of is.
And I think that's
what most people,
I think kind of see
right now, it's like,
we can all look back on videos
of Biden saying the reverse
and Harris saying the reverse
and McConnell
saying the reverse,
like it's across the board,
but then there's also just
like the reality of politics.
And if you've got the
power, you're gonna use it.
- These people doing jujitsu
to try to say McConnell,
isn't changing anything,
you know, because what he,
what he said the one time,
but not in all the other
interviews was that
when it's a, it's
divided government
when it's like a sitting
Democrat in the white house
and the Republicans,
and then now the centers
are coming out with like,
well, here's all the numbers
who, the number of times that,
look, it's a reversal
by the Republicans,
but cry me a river for the
Democrats who were upset over it
because they are the ones who
started this judicial war.
I've been following the
court for a long time
and practicing law
for a long time too.
And this started back when
they borked Robert Bork.
Prior to that, the
standard was to confirm
any reasonable jurist.
You, you knew
Republican presidents
were gonna pick conservative,
leaning justices.
Democratic ones were gonna
pick more liberal leaning ones.
And in the end it balances out.
Then, then Robert Bork
came up and they said,
no way, he's too conservative,
he's not getting on.
And that, that was the
first time that changed.
And then Miguel Astrada,
who was a star lawyer who
they wanted to elevate.
The Republicans wanted him
on the DC circuit
court of appeals.
And the Democrats are
quoted as saying they were,
they were afraid of him
because he was this dynamic,
Hispanic, rising star
in the Republican party.
And they didn't want him
because they knew he'd make
the Supreme court someday.
And they held up his nomination,
his confirmation
hearings for two years
to the point where the guy
finally had to say, I withdraw.
I gotta get on with my
life, support my family.
They started that.
And that's why later Mitch
McConnell started to slow roll
Barack Obama's judges that
led to Harry Reid thing.
I'm doing the nuclear
options, screw you,
we're getting rid
of the filibuster.
The Republican
stood up and said,
if you get rid of the filibuster
on lower court judges,
we're gonna do the same
view on Supreme Court judges
if we ever take power
in the Senate again.
Then the American electorate
put the Republicans in charge
of the Senate and Mitch
McConnell was true to his word.
I mean, it's, it
ain't beanbag, right?
And it's ugly and it's
gonna get even uglier.
I don't predict
anything kind or good
happening over the
next six months
when it comes to
the Supreme Court.
- Yeah, do you sense
there's any way
we can get out of this thing?
I mean, putting aside whether
it's just about Supreme Court,
just like everything
that everyone
feels so crazy all the time,
that politics is
everywhere all the time,
that it seems like half the
people wanna burn it down,
and the other, the other
half, according to them
are all racist anyway,
like you see a path
to getting out of it?
- I sadly, I think the
only thing that would do it
anytime soon is some sort of
national tragedy, you know?
And I don't mean like COVID,
I mean a war, you know,
obviously I'm not
wishing for that.
I'm just saying it
takes something truly
massive like that
to bring the country together.
And as tough as Corona has been,
it too has been politicized
and it hasn't had the
horrific shock value,
you know, in an instant,
the way say a 911 did or
I'm sure Pearl Harbor did,
where you just like
holding on to humanity
and looking at your
fellow human beings
with a little bit more kindness.
I don't know, I've
often thought, okay,
Trump is definitely such
an unusual leader, right?
And he's divisive of course,
but I don't think this goes away
if Donald Trump
loses this election.
I think Trump was definitely
a result of our
increasing partisanship
and, you know, the Republicans
wanted and needed a fighter
and they're not really concerned
that he doesn't speak
the Queen's English
and isn't necessarily, you
know, the perfect husband
and, you know, he's had some
moral failings, of course.
So I don't think even
if he, if he's gone,
whether it's Joe
Biden or somebody else
and other, even another
Republican in the office,
it gets better until we're
reminded of what matters.
What, why did these
people have so much time?
And I can say this
because I'm a woman,
to focus on their gender, right?
Like why, how they're
being discriminated against
as a woman.
How, like, I know they'll
say because we are,
you know, we're victims.
I don't believe that, because
I have other women to talk to
and I have other
black men to talk to.
And I have other trans
friends to talk to,
who don't run around
looking for ways
in which they've been
victimized all day, every day,
they're strong, they
lead their lives.
They suffer some adversity
like we all do time to time.
They forge forward, they
take life lessons from it,
they move on.
Like the amount of navel
gazing that goes on
and figuring out what
identity do I have
that will allow me to
embrace the victim ideology
is a total waste of time.
- Yeah, well, it's,
it's miserable.
It won't get you anywhere.
And look, even for you,
it's not that being a
woman in the news business
is the easiest thing.
I mean, bombshell is sort
of, it's sort of about that,
but you pretty much
just kept moving forward
and it basically worked.
- Well, I don't, I've never
liked to think of myself
as a victim.
And I recognize
that doesn't mean
I've never been one, right?
Like, I had, I had
a terrible stalker,
a felonious stalker in my
life who went to prison
for a very long time
after he stalked me.
And, and I had been bullied
by some very powerful figures,
but I never call
myself a victim.
I always call myself
a target, right?
Like I was a target
of that stalker
and I was a target
of certain people,
and that's fine, I
can get past that.
Like eventually you're
not a target anymore.
And the more like you get
ensconced in that,
whoa is me ideology,
even if you deserve it,
even if you do deserve empathy
and you have been victimized,
the worse it is
for you, you know,
it just leads to a constant
cyclone of negativity,
sadness, anger around you.
And you got to, as
a gift to yourself,
pull yourself out of that.
I don't know, I don't care
if it's cognitive
behavioral therapy
where you just gotta think
of a picture of your dog,
like do, do whatever
you needed to do
to get yourself out of that.
When you don't, it leads
to bad things in your life,
your happiness level
goes down, not up, right?
If you just think of yourself
as victimized all the time.
So I don't, I don't
understand why more people
don't get that.
I think people are sort
of looking for a reason
to feel victimized, to
find their posse, you know,
like to feel like they're
bonded to other people
in the same position.
I think this is why
women get mad at me
when I won't say I'm
a feminist, you know,
they, they want me in the posse
and they don't get my stiff arm
on some of their favorite words.
But I find the other,
the opposite worldview,
much more conducive to success.
- Yeah, your, your
kids are pretty young,
but do you sense that ideology
leaking into their world
either through school
or whatever messages
they're getting
or friend groups,
whatever it is?
- Very much so.
And Doug and I are really
trying to counter program that,
you know, it's like my, my
son Yates went into school,
this, this past year, last year,
one of his best
friends is black.
His parents are friends of ours.
And these two guys
are just buddies.
Now they're just buddies,
they just hang out,
they have play dates.
And by the end of
the year, you know,
the messaging to the
black child was basically,
you've been oppressed,
your parents, your
ancestors had been oppressed
since the beginning of time.
And the message to my son was,
and you are the oppressor
and they're sowing,
they're sowing division.
We're non existent.
These are just sweet boys who
love to be with each other.
Like, and, and by the way,
this other little boy's parents
didn't appreciate that either.
It wasn't, you know,
a white, black thing.
It was just a divisive thing
that doesn't help anybody.
I've, it's been painful to me.
You know, it's, it's really
been painful to watch
because I see like my
daughter's best friend is,
she's black, she's, her mother
is white, her father's black,
she's mixed race, but
they don't see color.
These girls, they go
out, they do fun things.
You know, you hardly
wouldn't even remark
on this girl's skin coloring
in describing her to anybody,
but all around us, people
are trying make her notice
to know that there's a
difference between them
and that it's awful,
and that, you know,
one person's distant,
distant, distant relatives,
or maybe not even
their relatives,
but just people who had
the same color of skin
did something
awful to, you know,
people who share the
other skin color.
And I just, I don't see, I
don't see how that's helping,
I believe much more in the
Martin Luther King dream
of seeing the two, you know,
the black kid and the white
kid walking down the street,
holding hands as it was
happening, it's still happening.
- Yeah, well, I
know you know this,
but according to
critical race theory,
it's not enough
to be not racist.
You have to be
actively anti-racist.
So your daughter not seeing
color, they would argue,
I mean, this is in the
critical race literature,
like they would literally argue
that that in and of itself
is racism because that status
quo upholds the structure
by itself.
- I mean, I think the only
response to that is fight me.
It's absurd, that is absurd.
And if you're listening
to that nonsense,
good luck.
We can't have an
honest conversation if
it begins like that.
- Yeah, speaking of nonsense,
we talked a little bit about
Trump and you know, you,
you were obviously in the midst
of it with him at some level
and the fights and the
media and all that stuff.
What do you make of
the Biden situation?
Do you think he's okay?
- I mean, obviously
he's struggling
with the effects of old
age to put it charitably.
You can see it.
There's, there's
really no denying it.
And it does at times
feel like the Democrats
are really just trying to
get him over the finish line.
Like did you see the woman,
the liberal woman when
she heard that RBG died
and she'd sent out this
video, it's spectacular.
And she's like "You
had one thing to do,
you just had to get
through to January of 2012"
of 2021, she was so upset.
I think that's kind of
how a lot of Democrats
are looking at Biden.
Like just STFU and get
him over the finish line,
just get him to just
shut up, not happening.
No one gives a damn that he
can't put the words together.
Like he's gonna
sign the right laws,
Harris is gonna make
them and we'll be fine.
Like he's a hell of a lot
better than, you know,
scary orange man.
That's what, that's
how they see it, right?
And I do wonder whether it
would be a Harris administration
either secretly or, you
know, soon if Biden wins.
- That seemed like such
a bizarre plan though,
'cause I'm, I'm
kind of with you,
that I think that was the plan,
but they didn't expect him
to break down this quickly.
And I don't even know who, I
mean by "they" cause it's like,
who are they?
Are we talking about the DNC?
Or are we talking about
like the Clinton machine
or whatever that is.
But I think they didn't
expect that the collapse,
his sort of mental state was
gonna just collapse so quickly.
But then doesn't it seem
odd that they would choose
Kamala Harris who was
polling at like 3%
within her own party
and was out way faster
than many of the
other candidates?
Like it just all
seems so bizarre.
- Oh, I think this is, you know,
they're very committed
to identity in the
Democratic Party,
you know?
And again, I do
make a distinction.
Like some of my best
friends are Democrats.
They don't think
about this shit.
Like they don't think about
any of this, like they're-
- So makes them, what
makes them Democrats then
at this point 'cause that's
what I'm trying to figure out.
'Cause you know-
- Issues.
- I have those friends
too, that's the world.
So like what kind of issue is,
is like a sensible
democratic issue to you?
- Like-
- What would they say?
- So my two best friends in
the world live in the Midwest.
One lives in Detroit
and one lives in Chicago
and one's a Dem and
one's a Republican.
And my, my Democrat friend,
you know, she's pro choice,
she's pro Obamacare,
she's pro environment,
she's, she doesn't mind
expansive government.
Right, she thinks the
government has a meaningful role
to play in helping the poor
and the underprivileged.
But when it comes to
these cultural issues,
she's kind of like,
"Oh, stop it, stop it."
You know, like we're all normal.
We don't need to obsess
about this stuff.
And it's not just race,
it's like race and gender
and all this stuff.
All of it is that people
are latching onto right now.
And I would say my
Republican friend there
is kind of the reverse of
her on some of those issues,
but lands in the same spot.
And, and we just, when I think
of my democratic friends,
they're like her, they're
like my friend who's great.
They're not obsessed
with this stuff,
but the left has gotten so loud
and they've gotten
control of such large
and important cultural
institutions that they're,
they're having
their way, you know,
they're having their way.
And I know like Douglas
Murray has been saying,
that's why people
need to speak up.
You know, the silent
majority needs to speak up.
And I realized easier
said than done,
given the cancel
culture we're in.
But until we get to the point
where people stand up and say,
I'm not gonna let you
do that to my child,
or I'm not gonna let
you do that to me.
I'm not gonna let you, he says,
you should stand up
at your workplace
that's trying to make you
swallow critical race theory
and say, I will, I
refuse to allow you
to re-racialize my
company, my city, myself,
but man, that's gonna take guts.
- Yeah, there's a, since
you mentioned Douglas,
one of his best
lines is he says,
"One day the barbarians
will be at the gate
and we'll debate, we'll be
debating what gender pronouns
to call them".
And I think that's just like,
it's such a perfect
summation of the whole thing.
Like there were real
problems out there
and instead we've decided
to debate gender pronouns
and that's not to be
dismissive of trans people.
- I mean, you have to say
that because you're worried
they're gonna come for
you, you know what I mean?
It's like I have,
I have such a long record of
standing up for trans people.
I have a trans
person in my family.
I got nothing
against trans people,
but the trans people I
know, they they're upset
by the hard vitriolic responses
the trans community has
when you don't wanna change
the spelling of women.
You know, they're like what the,
and it's like, who are
these trans activists?
Who do they, who are
they speaking for?
Because you know,
there's a, there's a,
a trans woman in my family.
She wants to be called a woman.
She doesn't want a
different, an X in the name.
She doesn't want you to,
she doesn't wanna have
to declare her pronouns.
The whole point of
transitioning over was to right.
So it's like, and I realize
not everybody feels that way,
but like the people
who speak the loudest
would have you believe they're,
this is how it has to be.
If there's any divergence,
if there's any discussion of,
you know, the napoli of
choices and the consequences,
you're bad.
That isn't true.
- Yeah, yeah, all right.
I want to, I wanna finish up
by talking about your podcast
a little bit and what
you're gonna be doing.
And I think I'm gonna be on
one of the first episodes.
I hope I don't
fuck it up for you.
That would, that would be-
- Me too.
- That would be pretty terrible,
but real quick, because
we only mentioned COVID
for just a second.
And since you're in New
York and I'm in L.A,
so these are two of the
sort of most lockdown places
with mayors that seem
to be more than happy
to keep us in this
perpetual state forever.
What's your basic take
about COVID at this point?
Like what should we be doing?
Should Trump have done more?
Can we just leave
it up to the states?
Are we ever going
to end all this,
the whole, the whole
shebang, Megan Kelly.
- Well, we're definitely
gonna end it all.
We are, that sounds ominous.
It's all gonna end.
- What do you know.
- This craziness will,
it will end.
And I think it will end,
you know, relatively soon
because I do think
they'll find a vaccine,
people will take it,
that'll calm the nerves.
They're getting better at
treating it, that's good.
You know, we're making progress.
We have some of the best
medical minds in the world,
in the United States and
they're all working on it
and outside the
United States too.
You know, I'm torn on this
because we've lost
people we love to COVID
and I know it's real,
you know, it's real
and it can be brutal,
but you know,
there's also an overreacting
that's kicked in
that's gotten kind
of out of hand.
You know, and I, I look
at my seven year old
who thankfully is in school,
but all day with the mask,
at recess has to
run with a mask on
and I, I'll take
it and we'll do it,
'cause I'm grateful that
the teachers are there
and this is the price we
pay for getting into school.
But I don't think
it's necessary.
I don't think, I
think that's too much.
And I think, you know,
walking around New York city,
you have to have a mask
on, on the sidewalk.
I don't think that's necessary.
I think if you can socially
distance on the sidewalk,
you're fine, you know.
I think we have to find a way
of going through the crisis
instead of just trying
to go around it.
There's just, we're not
gonna permanently be able
to go around it.
And I just think the
massive economic destruction
that's happened,
has been downplayed
or ignored or mocked, in a way
that's also really hurtful.
I look at my favorite
restaurant tours here
who are really struggling and,
you know, we make donations,
but it's teaspoons in the
ocean, that's not gonna do it.
And you know, there's sort of
a collective shoulder shrug.
So I guess my overall take
is I wish we had found a way
to protect the
vulnerable, you know,
seniors people, people
who are immunocompromised
and to forge forward
more robustly earlier on
so that we could have starved
off some of the economic pain.
I think the, you
know, the deaths,
then the numbers should be
lower, but they were coming,
you know, something
to invent this virus,
they were coming, it's a thing.
And unfortunately has
its favorite targets
and those people need
to be really careful,
you know, really careful.
And some of them, I
love having my family.
Anyway, so that's sort
of a meandering answer,
but it's, it's a
complicated issue.
And I think people who
are like "Open back up,
no mask, that's it"
I think that's too
extreme, right?
But I think "Shut
down, stay shut down,
you know, no restaurants, no
schools, masks everywhere.'
That seems too hysterical to me.
- Yeah, what do you think about
just like the social cost?
Like one of the things
that I think about a lot
is that the fact that
we're all wearing masks.
Like if I go to the
supermarket now,
I'm usually in a baseball
cap, sunglasses and a mask.
So in effect, you can't
see any part of my face,
which at some level it's nice,
because sometimes
people come up to me
and that way I can be
like totally anonymous,
which is nice.
But like, we, we sorta don't
look at each other anymore.
You know what I mean?
Like, even if you don't
have sunglasses on,
this thing that you can't
read someone's face.
I noticed that this
a lot with cashiers,
like, 'cause I really do try to,
it's one of the things that
I really worked on in August
when I was off the grid,
just like all my interactions
being as valuable as they could,
even just with random people,
but like even cashiers,
like you've no
longer, no one smiles,
you don't see smiles anymore.
And I'm worried that when you
then add social media to it,
how we're all on our computers
all day and our phones,
and then you take
away like another part
of the human element,
that that's like leading
us to something else
that's seriously dangerous.
- You, you've been off the
Upper West side for too long,
because no one smiles
at you here in New York.
I haven't noticed a
single difference.
If you're the one smiling
at everybody, you weird.
You're weird.
- Yeah, the weird guy.
- So it's been no
problem at all.
We're, we're just sort
of holding steady here.
I don't know, I think the
problem is much bigger
than you just pointed out.
I think, you know,
you hit on it a bit,
which is the technology
and how that's dividing us.
And we willingly signed
onto those kinds of lives
for too long, I am convinced
that a backlash is coming,
that the iPhone will be put
down by millions of people
because it's done a ton of
damage, especially to our kids.
And I think, you know,
the loss of the bowling
league and the church groups
and, you know, sort
of the, the clubs
has been a real loss to America
because it's the loss
of connection and caring
and, you know, willingness to
take care of one's neighbor
when he falls.
You know, the mask, I
don't know, it's temporary
and I think people will get
over, it's kind of annoying.
My friend was saying she was
upset because her son has acne
and it's aggravating the acne.
And all I could think back
to was my high school years
when I had bad acne and
I would've loved a mask.
It's the safe thing to do.
- The grass is always greener.
All right, well I think, I
think we got a sense of it,
but what is the Megan
Kelly Show gonna be about.
You're doing this thing,
you're doing three days
a week, is that right?
- Yeah, we're gonna start with
three and see how that goes.
And it's gonna start
now with audio.
We're just going to,
not with a video,
we're gonna start
with only audio,
which I think will be
kind of fun, you know.
It's like I had the microphone,
the headphones on the other day
and it just felt kind of cool.
It just feels pretty
cool to be in charge.
So the, I wanna do what people
like you are doing, Dave,
you know, I wanna have
open honest conversations
about tough issues and
be fearless in doing it.
I really do.
And I think one good thing,
you know, for better, for worse
about being me is I,
for whatever reason,
they tend to write
a lot of headlines
about my news coverage
and that's good, right?
That's good because I want
people to come on the show
and get headlines.
I want people to start
seeing that it's okay
to talk about the
difficult issues.
And in fact, if you
actually want any buy in,
you gotta let the
people weigh in
and just do it fearlessly
and relentlessly.
That's what I wanna do.
- All right, well, we
are gonna put a link
to the Megan Kelly Show
podcast right below
and Megan Kelly like a true
broadcast professional,
I'm gonna let you
sign off this episode
of the Rubin Report.
Take us home.
- This is Megan Kelly reporting
live on the Dave Rubin show.
See you next time.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about the media,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our media playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out the full episode playlist,
they're both right over
here and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.